un recipiente de reacción de un litro
contiene 1.2 moles de monóxido de
carbono 1.5 moles de hidrógeno gaseoso y
2.0 moles de metanol gaseoso como
cambiara la presión total conforme el
sistema alcanza el equilibrio a una
temperatura constante bueno el monóxido
de carbono reacciona con el hidrógeno en
una relación 1 a 2 para producir metanol
y esta es una reacción reversible
también sabemos que la constante de
equilibrio para esta reacción es de 14.5
a una cierta temperatura y sabemos que
la temperatura es constante vamos a
resolver este problema en dos partes en
la primera parte vamos a calcular el
cociente de reacción para saber si
nuestro sistema se encuentra en
equilibrio o no entonces para esta
reacción nuestro cociente de reacción q
es igual a la concentración del producto
en este caso el h3 o metanol entre la
concentración de hidrógeno gaseoso
al cuadrado porque tenemos este
coeficiente es tequio métrico y también
en el denominador tenemos la
concentración de monóxido de carbono
entonces para calcular que necesitamos
sustituir las concentraciones que
tengamos en este instante de tiempo en
particular y podemos calcular las
concentraciones usando el volumen del
recipiente que es de un litro y los
moles porque sabemos que la
concentración es simplemente moles entre
el volumen
pero como aquí se divide todo entre 1
las concentraciones iniciales serán las
mismas que el número de moles entonces
si sustituimos eso la concentración
inicial del monóxido de carbono es 1.2
molar la del hidrógeno es 1.5 molar y la
del metanol es 2.0 molar ahora sí ya
podemos sustituir estas concentraciones
en nuestra expresión de q entonces
tenemos 2.0 en el numerador
y en el denominador tenemos 1.5 al
cuadrado por 1.2 y al calcular esto con
la calculadora yo obtuve que el valor de
q para este instante en particular
usando estas concentraciones es 0.74 y
esto significa que bueno ya sabemos que
q no es igual a café y eso significa que
no nos encontramos al equilibrio no
al equilibrio
así que por lo tanto las presiones van a
cambiar sin dudas porque el sistema aún
va a tratar de alcanzar el equilibrio y
bueno otra cosa que podemos hacer usando
el cociente de reacción es conocer cómo
cambiarán las concentraciones porque
ahora que conocemos el valor del
cociente de reacción podemos decir que
nuestro cociente de reacción
jose es menor que k y podemos visualizar
esto en una recta numérica
entonces si analizamos todos los valores
posibles de q sabemos que cuando q es
igual a cero eso significa que tenemos
todos los reactivos todos los reactivos
y cuando q es infinitamente grande
entonces tenemos todos los productos
todos los productos
así que en medio tenemos todos los
valores posibles
aquí lo único que nos preocupa es
observar el valor relativo de cv y de
acá para poder analizar cómo cambian las
concentraciones entonces q vamos a
ponerlo en la línea numérica se
encuentra por aquí y acá que es 14.5
podemos decir que se encuentra por aquí
entonces esta es nuestra q y esta es acá
claramente podemos ver que q es menor
que acá entonces para que se alcance el
equilibrio
las concentraciones tenderán hacia la
derecha para que que se acerque más al
valor de k es decir que la reacción se
favorecerá hacia los productos
hacia los productos
entonces si regresamos a nuestra
reacción balanceada miren lo que pasará
es que la reacción se favorecerá hacia
los productos por eso resaltó esta
flecha de arriba un poco más y ya
podemos saber cómo es que esto puede
afectar a la presión total porque
buscamos la presión total para un
sistema que contiene muchas moléculas
gaseosas y sabemos que la presión total
está relacionada con los moles de gas en
el sistema entonces si se favorece en
los productos del lado de los productos
tenemos un molde gas y como reactivos
empezamos con tres moles de gas así que
estamos favoreciendo el lado que tiene
menos moléculas de gas
eso significa que conforme se favorecen
los productos disminuye el número de
moléculas gaseosas en el sistema y por
lo tanto eso disminuye la presión total
entonces la respuesta es que la presión
total disminuye conforme la reacción
alcanza el equilibrio y es
porque nuestro cociente de reacción q es
menor que k